[Musica]
ho l'abitudine ad iniziare dicendo ciao
internet qua non tanto perché ci siete
non solo voi ma anche quelli che ci
stanno guardando da online e che ci
riguarderanno che mi riguarderanno
peggio per loro ha registrato quindi se
mi state vedendo registrati qua sotto
c'è il box dei commenti lasciate un
commento
detto questo vi devo parlare di una cosa
particolare non finiamo in leggerezza al
contrario finiamo forse un po pesanti di
una sorta di segreto condiviso da parte
di un intero mercato quello
dell'advertising online di cui in genere
non si parla in cui si è riusciti a
parlare solo negli ultimi mesi ed è
importante da capire tutta la nostra
storia parte da un termine particolare
creator il creatore di contenuti come
che ietro si sta affermando forse non
avete ancora sentito dire da tanti in
realtà avete sentito dire alcuni dei
creatori youtuber gli influencer i
blogger tutte quelle persone che hanno
creato un media nuovo
se avete dei figli e probabilmente
maggiore la maggior parte
dell'intrattenimento di cui lo
usufruiscono non è fatto da una
televisione non è fatto da un film
alcune cose sono serie ma il fatto da
contenuti generati da e per alcuni
utenti
il creator lo youtuber influenzali
instagram air sono dei lavori a tutti
gli effetti si è riusciti infatti a
creare un complesso ecosistema che porti
beneficio monetario alla piattaforma che
li ospita
e a loro che invece diventano promotori
di se stessi il veicolo è sempre quello
advertising la pubblicità quella
pubblicità in cui i contenuti che loro
creano diventano parte di un catalogo
che viene proposto a degli inserzionisti
pubblicitari e davanti alla fine dei
filmati e sotto le loro fotografie
trovate pubblicità di una serie di
investitori pubblicitari
questo
muove un meccanismo però un filo
perverso in un mondo pieno e
completamente sovrabbondante di questo
tipo di contenuti
l'obiettivo è vincere su una cosa che è
la cosa più scarsa in questo momento
online la vostra attenzione il vostro
tempo
avete un numero di ore limitate da
dedicare a questa cosa per vincere
all'interno di questa gara bisogna
scegliere eccellere in cosa in contenuti
che a volte si eccellere in bravura
a volte sì ma come nelle gare ogni tanto
qualcuno usa metodi non proprio
ortodossi per vincere
esiste anche un doping digitale il
doping digitale è dato per prendendo
degli argomenti che si sa già che li
interessano e sfortunatamente gli esseri
umani sono delle belle persone diceva
luca prima ma nelle pulsioni di base non
sono così delle belle persone sono due
le grandi pulsioni eros e thanatos amore
e morte pulsione di vita si dice e
pulsione di morte sono dei nomi molto
belli per dire poi delle cose che tanto
belle non sono sono sesso nudità tutta
la parte della sfera sessuale in
qualunque ragione dalla curiosità di
base al sesso completato e dall'altra
parte morte violenza aggressione
abbiamo un amore viscerale nel vedere
qualcuno che si fa male abbiamo amore
viscerale nel guardare spasmodicamente
le esecuzioni
vogliamo vedere la violenza nei telefilm
vogliamo vedere la violenza vogliamo
seguire la la violenza verbale che tutto
questo crea un circolo vizioso maggiore
è il contenuto strillato maggiore è la
quantità di pornografia maggiore è la
quantità di contenuti questionabili
maggiore la curiosità maggiore la
curiosità maggiore sono le
visualizzazioni maggiori sono le
visualizzazioni
l'introito che è buffo
e buffo perché perché nella realtà
con questo meccanismo sollecitiamo la
creazione incentiviamo la creazione di
contenuti che sappiamo che bene alla
società non fanno la cosa buffa è che a
incentivarlo sono spesso le grandi
marche in questo circolo perverso
si sa che a un certo punto qualcosa deve
succedere perché si monta tutto questo e
nel frattempo la cosa assordante è il
silenzio del mercato perché lo si sa che
ci sono quei tipi di contenuti il gioco
la parola in questo caso che tutte le
piattaforme usano è è un problema
marginale
già perché su centinaia di miliardi i
contenuti e vero stiamo parlando di
punti percentuali ma marginale che si
autoalimenta che auto alimenta il fatto
di proporre contenuti sempre più
violenti sempre più esplicitamente
sessuali e nel frattempo dire va tutto
bene ti assicuro investitore
pubblicitario che la mia è una
piattaforma sicura e da lì lo stiamo
vedendo la lontano l'asteroide ma
continua ad arrivare
l'asteroide confisce con una cosa
particolare con quel nome strano ad poca
lizza crasi tra due parole advertising e
apocalypse la dà poca lips è un fenomeno
che inizia a fine dell'anno scorso
inizio di quest anno su una particolare
piattaforma non farò nomi di piattaforme
perché non importa il problema è nato su
una particolare ma non ha senso fare
bashing di questa stiamo parlando di
qualcosa del mercato non di una
piattaforma in particolare e non voglio
che questo mio racconto di 20 in
qualcosa ad personam ho percepito come
tale
su questa piattaforma ci si accorge a un
certo punto che ad esempio i contenuti
terroristici hanno dei meravigliosi
banner di inserzionisti pubblicitari
già
il caso possibile marginale ricordatevi
marginale il problema ed è la parola
marginale perché non significa solo che
è ridotto ma è che è messo ai margini
eli non svegliate lo è in questa parte
salta fuori però come al solito dal
singolo episodio
scavando salta fuori il marcio e il bar
ci sono migliaia centinaia di migliaia
di contenuti di razzismo che inneggiano
la supremazia bianca che inneggiano al
al nazismo storico negazionisti
contenuti che fanno male alla società ma
che hanno dei vistosi banca si sapeva
anche prima ho fatto le prime
segnalazioni alla stessa piattaforma a
metà del 2009 dicendo che c'erano dei
siti con contenuti pedopornografici che
avevano dei meravigliosi banner ma non
si fa abbastanza rumore vi ricordate
marginale questa volta cambia qualcosa
questa volta cosa cambia cambia che
grandi investitori pubblicitari ei
clienti verizon mates colore al mcdonald
royal mail facebook decidono di
rimuovere totalmente l'investimento
pubblicitario dalla piattaforma e
guardate che strano quando sono decine
se non centinaia di milioni di euro
tolti nell'advertising il problema
marginale non diventa più marginale e ci
si muove voi iniziate dire che bravi i
brand l'hanno affatto una cosa etica ma
non prendiamoci in giro per cortesia
sette adulti sono adulto siamo vaccinati
più o meno tutti grazie a dio
ogni riferimento è puramente
intenzionale non l'hanno fatto perché
sono delle belle persone hanno fatto per
una cosa che è il mio lavoro di tutti i
giorni nell'azienda che dirigo e della
reputazione che cos'è la reputazione è
una percezione che ha a che fare con
quello che dicono di te e quando
qualcuno sui giornali inizia dirti che
la società pippo finanzia il terrorismo
che la società pippo finanzia il
neonazismo che la società pippo finanzia
la pedofilia
e allora ti fermi e inizia a dire no
aspetta un secondo
così le cose non possono andare
ovvio ancora una volta quando tu
racconti queste cose
ritorna sempre la solita faccia capisce
è un problema marginale già e lui smith
che dice alta carica di google in questo
caso ma ancora una volta non
focalizzatevi sull'azienda
focalizzatevi sul mercato
dell'advertising e su alcune incide di
più semplicemente perché incide di più
nell nel totale dell'advertising dovremo
stringere un po le nostre pollici policy
aumentare un po l'analisi manuale così
penso che it's gonna be ok andrà tutto
bene ora se c'è una cosa che ho imparato
in vent'anni in cui lavora nel digitale
e che quando fai affermazioni del genere
in genere portano sfiga è una costante
universale e così è anche qui perché qui
inizia a parlare di fiducia
inizia a parlare del fatto che hai
proposto dei contenuti
e a questo punto sai che c'è qualcosa
che non va nel tuo processo di
approvazione e ai venduti come normali
il togli grande analisi grande dispendio
di intelligenza artificiale nel
frattempo ci sono un po di quelli che in
gergo militare vengono chiamati
collateral damage ed è il termine carino
per dire quando uccisi dei civili in
mezzo ai militari cioè nel frattempo
vengono dei monetizzate cioè si toglie
l'advertising non solo a quelli davvero
violenti ma ad esempio ai giornali radio
che parlano i neo nazismo come fai a
distinguere chi parli neonazismo
incitandole all alto non puoi e quindi
un po di collateral damage ma nel
frattempo ti accorgi che il problema non
è così ridotto vi ricordate eravamo
intorno a marzo di quest'anno ma circa
un mese fa si scopre che un altro grande
pacchetto venduto come meraviglioso con
punteggiando le icone cuoricini tanto
meraviglioso non è una di queste parti
una di quelle che ha più soldi da
investire
sono le aree dedicate ai
i bambini ci sono delle applicazioni che
sono esattamente fatte for kids non
hanno tutti i contenuti ti assicurano
che hanno i contenuti che vanno bene per
i bambini ed è enormemente profittevole
perché è profittevole
perché quel tipo di applicazione ad
esempio sono date sono usate essendo
fatte per bambini incidentalmente da dei
bambini che non hanno l'abitudine ad
andare avanti nella pubblicità a
cancellare la pubblicità un'abitudine di
averla davanti come fosse un mezzo
televisivo e vedere grandi quantità
questo significa tantissimi minuti di
visualizzazione significa tantissimi
visualizzazioni significa un mare di
soldi
assolutamente sì e di parte un altro dei
grandi problemi che viene definito elsag
ei questo che vedete dietro è un frame
di uno di quei filmati dove a elsa la
principessa disney è totalmente estraneo
da tutto questo sfortunatamente i primi
contenuti che saranno stati trovati e
riversavano proprio su quella che era la
star ha letto del momento è il sangue
vengono strappati dente qui viene fatto
violenza vi ricordate eros e thanatos
ambedue funzionano anche nei bambini il
bambino cerca con curiosità quelle cose
che normalmente gli sono proibite e
normale ma su quella piattaforma e
contenuti c'erano e ce n'erano di due
tipi diversi uno peggio dell'altro uno
per monetizzare sui bambini
e allora inizia ad avere la finte peppa
pig a cui fanno le peggio cose
dell'universo violenza rapimenti
uccisioni dalle papig decapitate in
contenuto per bambini vi ricordate
stiamo parlando i contenuti che una
piattaforma ti diceva che erano ok per
dei bambini fino a tre papi che beve
candeggina
la prima cosa che vorreste far vedere ai
vostri figli no vedere come bere
candeggina
ma vi ricordate sempre un problema
marginale marginale talmente marginale
che sono circa 50mila canali che vengono
rimossi e oltre 2 milioni di video e
come sempre come prima
quando vai a controllare a scavare
quando pensi di aver trovato il male
perciò spesso stai solo grattando la
costa perché sopra di questo ce ne sono
una serie di altri di contenuti ci sono
una serie di filmati che sessualizzano i
ragazzini e che ospitano milioni di
commenti di pedofili che raccontano che
cosa farebbero a quel bambino in quel
filmato particolare di ginnastica
artistica dove il close up dove le
zoomate non sono esattamente dove ti
aspetti che si siano su un filmato di
ginnastica artistica di bambini
prepuberi anche in questo caso l è
marginale sono solo 150mila i video che
sono stati rimossi
in questo caso e oltre 650.000 video
ulteriori a cui è stato disabilitato
la possibilità di commentare e qui e qui
dobbiamo fermarci un secondo e dobbiamo
iniziare a farci delle domande
la prima di questa domanda a che fare
con una parola importante che è
responsabilità la responsabilità di un
mercato quello dell'advertising
qui non stiamo parlando di
responsabilità legale togliamo di mezzo
quello i contenuti non sono caricati da
questa piattaforma per alcune
giurisdizioni non hanno nemmeno
l'obbligo di quello che viene chiamato
l'avvio di sorveglianza cioè di
controllare che cosa c'è per ospitarle
per averle sulla piattaforma
se qualcuno l'ha segnata da li rimuovono
ma vogliamo chiederci se invece un
minimo di responsabilità c'è quando non
solo le ospiti ma decidi volontariamente
di monetizzarle cioè di profittare
perché vi ricordate vi prende soldi chi
fa i filmati ma la metà circa finiscono
in mano alla piattaforma quando decidi
monetizzare vogliamo parlare della
responsabilità di dire che hai un
inventario di contenuti 6 sicuri e
quando non lo è vogliamo parlare della
responsabilità di chi ti dice che sono
filmati per bambini e per bambini non
sono il ritorna la parola del marginale
è vero tecnicamente è assolutamente vero
nella grande quantità sono pochi ma
quando quei pochi sono milioni
allora forse è arrivato il momento di
fare una scelta coraggiosa di dire che
magari non si è tenuto per legge ma
questa cosa marginale diventa perde una
cosa importante diventa cioè una
priorità perché proprio questione di
priorità non è che la piattaforma a
piacere
sono convinto davvero ma non so non per
piaggeria
sono convinto che nessuno abbia
interesse a ospitare i contenuti
pedofili sono convinto che nessuno abbia
piacere a ospitare quel tipo di
contenuti il problema è che rimane il
mar cina da quando da marginale dovrebbe
diventare la mia priorità priorità per
tante ragioni priorità perché è
necessario qualcuno proverà è ci
proveranno sicuramente nei prossimi mesi
a raccontarvi che è difficile e quasi
impossibile
già è impossibile trovare tutti quelli
che sono sicuramente legati a quelli non
è impossibile trovare un sacco di
contenuti e intanto de monetizzarli poi
si vedrà che cosa fare perché il
problema qui non è che non è possibile
demonizzare si potrebbe si potrebbe
bloccare subito questo problema basta
togliere la monetizzazione da tutti i
contenuti ma guarda che strano
per qualcuno che fa miliardi di dollari
all'anno toccare i soldi è molto più
importante che toccare al fatto di fare
la cosa giusta priorità e quando vi
diranno che è impossibile che
l'intelligenza artificiale non ce la può
fare
dite a quella stessa azienda che non più
tardi nella settimana fa i miliardi di
galassie contenenti miliardi di stelle
un intelligenza artificiale ha trovato
un nuovo sistema solare nuovo hanno
scoperto nessuno ipotizzando nel
resistenza troviamo un nuovo sistema
solare meraviglioso kepler 90
complemente pianeti adatti alla vita una
di quelle cose che ti fanno dire al lod
science che è una pagina facebook che vi
consiglio di seguire
detto questo avete trovato un nuovo
sistema nell'universo e mi dite che non
siete riusciti a trovare due milioni di
contenuti a casa vostra
a me fa un filino di presa in giro
esiste una soluzione beh non so se
esiste la soluzione definitiva
alcune sono state trovate una di questa
importantissima e coinvolge braille bart
un sito di supremazia bianca l'avete
fosse sentito la casa dell'altra it che
ha perso negli ultimi anni circa 1000
investitori pubblicitari li hanno persi
perché investitore pubblicitario ha
deciso di fare la scelta giusta non
proprio che hanno persi principalmente
grazie allora un'iniziativa che si
chiama sleeping giants giganti dormienti
cosa fa semplice cerca su segnalazione
degli utenti quando c'è un contenuto
pubblicitario di qualcuno su quel sito e
manda tweet dove dice ciao nome della
marca lo sai che sei lì è davvero quello
il tuo scopo è davvero quella alla tua
mission sono quelli i tuoi valori e
guarda che strano dal i sistemi
spariscono c'era un vecchio detto che
diceva il più e badarci tre possibilità
1 giocare con la vostra attenzione
l'attenzione a quello che succede
attenzione da parte di chi attenzione da
parte dei brand delle marche
attenzione a non farsi abbindolare
attenzione a non credere a tutto quello
che ha già attenzione a dove mettono i
propri soldi perché a quanto pare è vero
che i soldi possono essere usati male ma
il rimuovere la linfa dall'odio ottiene
come risultato per lo meno quello di non
incrementare il circolo dell'odio non
credo che sia sufficiente per cancellare
l'odio da online
credo che sia sufficiente per ridurlo in
maniera esponenziale
attenzione da parte delle piattaforme
perché quando c'è la reputazione di
mezzo c'è la si fa attenzione anche da
parte di ciascuno di voi
attenzione a trovare quel banner in quel
posto e alzare la mano perché perché
tutto questo è una scelta
la scelta di dove mettere i soldi
dell'azienda
e di fare perseguire il bene o per
seguire il bo perché non è male e solo
boh la scelta vostra di decidere che
brand usare a seconda della scelta che
prendono la scelta delle piattaforme di
adeguarsi a un mondo che cambia e la
consapevolezza da buddista una parola
fondamentale per me il fatto di esserci
il fatto di decidere consapevolmente il
fatto di sapere che avete la possibilità
di fare la differenza e guardate che
molto spesso è il tweet di un'unica
persona con una bella immagine una
fotografia
se non siete capaci di fare lo
screenshot fatti bella foto al vostro
monitor e twittate mandate sui due
dicendo ciao nome di grande marca perché
sei lì perché non controlli potete fare
molta più differenze milioni di euro voi
di tante altre persone e la differenza
la possono fare le grandi piattaforme
finisco tutti i miei video normalmente
con una parola latina che è estate
parati siate con il due parole latine
scusate
siate pronti siete pronti a cosa siete
pronti a fare la differenza perché in
questo caso è l'uomo che può fare
davvero la differenza
e come sempre anche come questa volta
grazie mille per avermi ascoltato e
estote parati
[Applauso]